défi communiste ou communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables limbo
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scoopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
lucas da silva cofondateur de scopeo et
je vous souhaite aujourd'hui la
bienvenue sur ce quatrième épisode de
notre série d'entrevues politique et
aujourd'hui nous sommes très honorés de
recevoir monsieur pierre haski mais
avant toute chose je laisse la parole à
emilien pouchain qui est également
membre de scopeo et il va poser le décor
de ce nouveau podcast
merci le cas bonjour ceux qui nous
écoutent les surtout bonjour à vous
pierre haski merci bonjour nous fait le
plaisir aujourd'hui de nous accorder
cette entrevue pour discuter de
géopolitique comme vous le faites au
quotidien notamment lors de vos
chroniques sur france inter plus
précisément le thème de cet entretien
sera la place de la france dans le monde
mais avant de démarrer cette entrevue
monsieur haïti je vous laisse vous
présenter brièvement
merci côté moi je suis d'abord et avant
tout un journaliste c'est un métier que
j'exerce depuis plus de 40 ans avec avec
bonheur et passion parce que c'est un
métier que j'ai choisi très jeune et que
j'ai toujours exercé sur le plan
international j'ai été trois fois
correspondant en afrique du sud à
l'époque de l'apartheid c'était à
l'époque pour l' agence france-presse
puis ensuite deux fois pour le quotidien
libération
j'ai passé 26 ans à libération dont deux
périodes lune comme correspondant à
jérusalem et l'autre en chine à pékin
donc voilà c'est ce qui a un peu
structuré ma maman parcours et et ma vie
de journaliste est là depuis maintenant
trois ans je suis chroniqueur à france
inter le matin dans la matinale à 8h15
la chronique géopolitique
j'ai également une chronique
hebdomadaire dans l'aube selon le
magazine locks et je suis par ailleurs
président de reporters sans frontières
qui est une sorte de de continuité ou de
poursuites par d'autres moyens de d'un
engagement en faveur voilà deux
de la liberté d'expression et de et
d'une action internationale
d'un côté avec l'information de l'autre
avec la défense du droit à l'information
qui est donc complémentaire
voilà merci monsieur à skis pour cette
brève présentation comment sont
directement dans le vif du sujet comme
et emilien l'a dit on va aborder la
question de la place de la france
aujourd'hui dans le monde et pour
commencer cette entrevue
nous avons marqué que la vision
française des relations internationales
a beaucoup évolué au fil des dernières
décennies
et on peut dire que les premières
présidence de la vème république sont
semblables de ce point de vue puisque
elles peuvent être qualifiés de golaud
mitterrandiste alors pouvez vous nous
définir en quoi consistait cette ligne
résolument française est selon vous
surtout les prisons macron s'inscrit-il
dans cette tradition géopolitique est
elle toujours pertinente aujourd'hui
selon vous alors c'est effectivement une
question intéresse parce que dans golo
mitterrandien il yad'abord de gaulle et
donc rendre lui cet hommage il a il a
façonné une posture internationale de la
france qui a marqué le pays depuis plus
d'un demi siècle et qui marque quasiment
tous les tous les présidents et
d'ailleurs c'est assez intéressant de
voir à quel point il ya aujourd'hui un
consensus politique en france pour se
réclamer de l'héritage du général de
gaulle y compris du côté du
rassemblement national qui est
l'héritier de ceux qui ont voulu
assassiner le chef général de gaulle à
l'époque de la guerre d'algérie et de
des lendemains de la guerre d'algérie ou
de de l'extrême gauche ou même de la
gauche traditionnelle souvenons nous
qu'en même de de françois mitterrand
qu'il a combattu simplement de gaulle à
avait une vision de la place de la
france dans le monde et d'une sorte de
2,2 g j'emploie le mot posture c'est un
petit peu négatif mais de deux dunes
d'un rôle particulier qui peut être
rapportée d'ailleurs au rôle particulier
que les américains se donne
point commun entre eux entre les deux
pays et que ce ce rôle sur mesure que de
gaulle c'était les façonner est resté et
a été repris par françois mitterrand une
fois qu'il est devenu président en 1980
ce qui a changé depuis
c'est que je pense que l'ambition
française de deux à la fois de jouer un
rôle dans le monde d'avoir un message
particulier apporté dans le monde à être
l'un des moteurs de la construction
européenne à avoir aussi une action sur
le plan militaire avec la projection de
trop et c'est tout ça reste valable
aujourd'hui ea mobile et l'esprit de
tous les présidents ce qui a changé
c'est évidemment que le le monde a
changé autour de nous et que la place de
la france n'est plus la même ce il faut
en être conscient
et que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
la france est un une puissance moyenne
dont la voix continue à porter parce
qu'elle est membre du consulter un
nombre permanents du conseil de sécurité
parce qu'elle a encore une action
militaire importante parce qu'elle a un
rôle moteur en europe mais qui il faut
bien le dire est bien moindre et à moins
d'impact que qu'elle ne pouvait la voir
il ya 30 40 50 50 ans voire plus encore
à l'époque du général de gaulle pour la
simple raison que le monde est
effectivement devenu multipolaire
c'était quelque chose qu'on qu'on
souhaitait et qui s'est produit ça se
produit d'une manière relativement
chaotique on y reviendra peut-être mais
dans ce monde multipolaire
la france est et et n'a plus la capacité
d' influence qu'elle avait autrefois
d'une certaine manière c'est un retour à
l'ordre normal des choses la france est
un pays de 65 millions d'habitants dont
l'économie a certes encore importante
mais n'a pas
le dynamisme que qui est nécessaire pour
peser dans ce monde et est donc à essaye
d'utiliser l'europe comme levier de deux
influences dans ce monde et emmanuel
macron est certes à la fois dans
l'héritage golo mitterrandien il l'a dit
lui même il l'avait dit dans un pendant
la campagne électorale d'ailleurs et en
même temps ils y apportent le regard de
quelqu'un de sa de sa génération et qui
est je pense relativement conscient de
des faiblesses et des vulnérabilités de
la france et qui essaye de jouer dix ans
au dessus de sa catégorie
c'est un peu la lune des constances
qu'on peut attribuer à la diplomatie
française depuis longtemps c'est qu'elle
essaye d'être un cran au-dessus de sa
catégorie de rester un interlocuteur est
un acteur qui compte sur la planète
malgré les handicaps dont dans dispose
dans l'eau dont souffre aujourd'hui la
france sur la scène internationale
voilà un peu résumé mais je pense que il
ya une certitude en tout cas qui est
partagée depuis un moment par par les
dirigeants français c'est cette idée que
si la france veut peser sur les affaires
du monde et faire passer un peu de sa
vision ses valeurs etc
ça ne peut se passer que à travers
l'europe qui est certes il doit y avoir
encore une diplomatie française
spécifique mais que l'europe est
forcément le bon niveau et on le voit
par exemple près c'est presque un
exemple d un cas d'école dans les
relations avec la chine
la france a certes des relations
importantes avec la chine mais c'est
l'échelon européen qui permet
aujourd'hui de peser face à un
mastodonte d'un milliard 400 millions
d'habitants qui a une forte conscience
des rapports de force
accor donc la ligne golo mitterrandiste
était comme vous venez de le dire basé
sur une certaine posture internationale
et sur une volonté d'indépendance
surtout et cette volonté d'indépendance
était basé sur leurs menus clairs et une
indépendance stratégique
on pourrait dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
possédons encore le la dissuasion
nucléaire mais que nous sommes
manifestement plus capable d'être
indépendant d'un point de vue
stratégique et militaire
on pourrait de ce point de vue parler du
des capacités de renseignement de la
logistique des capacités de transport
des munitions etc
pensez vous que la france seule puisse
avoir les moyens de ses ambitions
militaires
ou pensez-vous au contraire qu'une
qu'une armée crédible et autonome ne
pourrait être que le fruit d'un projet
de défense européenne je pense
qu'effectivement la france na na palais
de l'athénée lui véritablement ça reste
à voir
les moyens d'une autonomie ni
stratégique total je pense c'est une
illusion
et est ce elle l'est encore plus dans le
dans le monde actuel mais on le voit
aujourd'hui effectivement par exemple
prenons le principal le lieu
d'intervention aujourd'hui de l'armée
française le sahel le soutien logistique
et en matière de renseignement des états
unis est absolument vital capitale
lorsque les américains à l'époque de
trump ont voulu couper cette
intervention
quand le florence parly la ministre des
armées s'est précipité à washington pour
convaincre
avec succès d'ailleurs le les américains
de rester
et alors ce n'est pas très difficile
parce qu'en fait le pentagone était très
désireux de rester et et ça fait partie
de delair trump ou le président d une
chose et le pentagone ou le département
d'état en sont une autre
mais en l'occurrence le pentagone a
voulu rester et cette participation
américaine elle est bien le signe que la
france seule
nan
naples n'a pas les moyens de s'engager
l'autre exemple qui était très
intéressant d'ailleurs parce qu'il pose
tout un tas de questions
c'est l'armement on sait que le rafale
est un avion 100% français mais c'est
sans doute le dernier avion de combat
100% français et moi j'ai déjà souvenirs
là tout à fait personnel il se trouve
que juste après la fin de la guerre
froide donc au début des années 90 je me
suis retrouvé par hasard assis à côté du
chef de l'armée de l'air française et et
qui est un pilote lui-même qui était un
homme assez passionnante de dire et qui
m'expliquait pourquoi finalement le
rafale serait le dernier les radios
français et on parle de 25 ans et donc
il y avait déjà cette conscience parce
que c'était un avion qui avait été conçu
avant la fin de la guerre froide et à
l'époque la france avait voulu garder
l'intégralité de de son savoir-faire sur
la fabrication de cet avion
or si vous entrez dans un consortium
comme l'était l'eurofighter qu'est le
l'avion qui a été conçu par les anglais
les allemands et quelques autres pays
bas vous vous spécialisez et vous
abandonnez votre savoir faire sur le
train d'atterrissage où le réacteur où
le ou l'électronique de bord etc et donc
la france avait voulu dans une option
gaullienne traditionnel d'indépendance
conserver 100% de savoir faire est là et
le rafale qui est d'ailleurs une
réussite était s'inscrivait dans cette
lignée aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on voit
le successeur du rafale sera peut-être
un avion à bases franco-allemandes
s'appelle le scaf l'avion du l'avion de
combat du futur qui a été conclue la
décision de le lancer
c'est d'ailleurs intéressant a été prise
le trt
juillet 2010 8 au matin je donne cette
précision parce que dans l'après-midi
donald trump arrivée à paris vous
souvenez qu'il avait assisté au défilé
du 14 juillet et que ça lui avait
beaucoup plu et mais la veille il y
avait eu le matin un conseil des
ministres franco allemand
donc tous les ministres est une des
caractéristiques d'ailleurs des
relations franco allemandes qui n' a pas
d'équivalent dans le monde
tous les ministres français et allemands
se retrouvent autour de la même table
pour étudier les dossiers communs essais
de ce matin là qu'a été décidé le
lancement du scaf l'espagne s'est
ralliée d'ailleurs depuis à ce projet et
l'italie pourrait pourrait aussi s'y
rallier sauf que sa robe ça se heurte à
des difficultés assez considérable et on
voit bien aujourd'hui que le sort de cet
avion n'est toujours pas réglée il ya
des conflits sur le partage du des
tâches industrielles sur la propriété
intellectuelle et sur la responsabilité
du projet c'est très complexe et et je
sais que les industriels sont en ce
moment même en train de d'essayer de
résoudre un certain nombre de ces
problèmes parce que le temps presse et
normalement il doit y avoir une
un projet qui doit être soumis au
bundestag au parlement allemand pour
obtenir les financements et les
allemands voudraient le présenté avant
l'été
puisqu'en septembre il y aura des
élections et donc il voudrait que ce
soit fait avant donc on voit bien qu'on
est rentré dans une autre ère c'est à
dire celle du partage et non plus de
l'autonomie à 100% sur la fabrication
des matériels militaires
tout simplement parce que on en a pas
les moyens et parce que on veut aussi
entrer dans une logique européenne et
donc on a ce cet équilibre à trouver
entre conserver ce qui fait un un des
points forts de la présence
internationale de la france c'est à dire
une capacité militaire qu'une capacité
de projection et capacités décision
d'intervention qu'aucun autre pays de
l'ue
de l'union européenne n'a aujourd'hui
après le départ des britanniques et et
que et qui dans la relation franco
allemande était évidemment un atout pour
la france
et donc je tenterais bien sûr préserver
cette capacité maintenant et de l'autre
côté joué la carte européenne
il ya un équilibre à trouver dans la
mesure où on sait très bien à un moment
on a parlé de d'armée européenne je
pense que c'était une erreur de
communication du gouvernement parce que
on ne se dirige pas vers une armée
européenne y aura pas une armée dans
laquelle les soldats de toutes les
nationalités se retrouveront on parle de
de coopération d'interopérabilité de de
capacité commune mais pas d'une armée
intégrée
je pense que là on est dans l'utopie
total donc comment jouer entre cette
autonomie là et là la carte européenne
c'est tout l'enjeu des prochaines années
bien sûr et justement on va on va
rebondir sur cette question on va rester
sur ce thème de l'europe
et selon vous c'est une question quand
même qui préoccupe beaucoup aujourd'hui
l'ailé politique français est ce que la
france a nécessairement besoin d'union
européenne aujourd'hui pour s'affirmer
dans le monde
vous l'avez déjà vous avez déjà un petit
peu esquissé cette question doit-on
aller dans le sens d'une autonomie
stratégique ou d'une souveraineté
européenne comme le président macron le
souhaitent
en d'autres termes le destin français
est il nécessairement lié aujourd'hui à
celui de l'europe et sur cette
thématique on peut également se poser la
question qui est très légitime de la
conciliation entre l'idée de
souveraineté européenne et de
souveraineté nationale
oui c'est une question très très vaste
et effectivement on est aujourd'hui
confrontée à une question de définition
qu'est ce que la souveraineté est est ce
que la souveraineté nationale
aujourd'hui a encore du sens et est-ce
qu'elle n'est pas en fait un renoncement
à la souveraineté dans la mesure où un
état de la taille de la france ne pèsera
plus et subira
nécessairement les normes et les
impératifs décidée par les plus gros et
donc est ce que la souveraineté
aujourd'hui un sens au niveau national
ou est ce qu'elle doit au contraire être
partagé et reconstruite au niveau
européen moi je suis absolument
convaincu que que c'est au niveau
européen que ça se passera dans la
mesure où justement sur cette question
il ya une question fondamentale
aujourd'hui qui est celle des normes qui
fixe les normes dans le monde et jusqu'à
présent l'europe a été un continent qui
a initié beaucoup de normes
par exemple les normes environnementales
dans le monde sont très largement les
normes européennes
magique quand je vais car j'étais en
chine quand je lui eus en chine
c'était assez fascinant de voir comment
le l'industrie automobile chinoise par
exemple s'aligner sur les normes
européennes en permanence les normes
le dernier exemple qui restent qui
montre que l'europe garde cette cette
force c'est sur la protection des
données le rgp des européens donc le
règlement général sur la protection des
données qui s'applique à l'europe et
donc à la toutes les plateformes et c
est devenu de fait un standard beaucoup
plus large à l'échelle mondiale donc
c'est cette question elle est très
importante parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
monter en puissance un acteur qu'est la
chine qui veut être le porteur d'énormes
de demain et des standards
technologiques et des normes qui ne sont
pas nécessairement celles que nous
souhaitons donc comment continuer à
peser
si on n'est pas cet ensemble de 500
millions de personnes à l'échelle
européenne premier marché mondial
première le premier ensemble
géoéconomique jusqu'à présent et donc
c'est c'est toute la question de la
souveraineté et je pense que c'était
il ya une partie du débat
franco-français qui l'ignorent est qui
et qui raisonne en termes de
souveraineté basique qui est en contrôle
de nos frontières en contrôler
l'immigration puisque c'est souvent
l'arrière pensée numéro un et et qui ne
prend pas en compte cette dimension là
qui est celle qui pour autant façonnent
nos vies de demain parce que si les pays
européens agissent et séparément ils
seraient aujourd'hui les nécessairement
les j'allais dire les vassaux c'est un
peu c'est un peu fort et c'est un peu
péjoratif dans tout cas dans un état de
dépendance vis-à-vis d'un gros qui
serait sans doute dans notre cas des
états unis et que je ne pense pas que ce
soit souhaitable dans la mesure où on le
voit bien par rapport par exemple à
l'univers des gaffes à ces grandes
plateformes numériques
elles n'ont pas nécessairement les mêmes
règles que celles que nous souhaiterions
voir arts appliqués et pareil sur les
normes technologiques nous deviendrions
les sous traitants deux de ces grands
ensembles donc pour moi la souveraineté
doit être conçu de plus en plus comme un
enjeu européen
ce qui ne signifie pas évidemment la
disparition des nations et c'est là que
que tout le l'histoire récente de
l'europe devrait devrait nous nous nous
enseigne est effectivement l'objectif
n'est pas de faire disparaître la nation
française dans un super état
technocratique européen mais en revanche
que la défense de l'existence même de la
nation française n'a de sens que dans un
ensemble plus vaste qui partagent les
mêmes valeurs les mêmes
mêmes intérêts parce que c'est aussi ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui et qui étaient
peut-être moins évident il ya vingt ans
c'est que conçoit finlandais français ou
portugais sur un certain nombre d'enjeux
majeurs de la planète aujourd'hui que ce
soit évidemment le climat les relations
avec les gaffes ou où la stabilité en
méditerranée où les l'émergence de pôles
disruptif à nos frontières comme la
russie la turquie etc mais aussi la
négociation avec des gros ensembles
comme la chine
eh ben les européens ont des intérêts
communs ont véritablement des intérêts
communs et et ne peuvent les défendre
quand qu'en adoptant des positions
communes et donc d d d instance d'avoir
des instances de décision et de
d'élaboration de ces positions communes
essaient c'est tout l'apprentissage de
l'europe qui est extrêmement complexe
comme on le voit à chaque chaque fois
qu'un sujet arrive sur la table
d'accord donc nous nous devons parler de
l'europe et de la question de la
souveraineté nous allons maintenant
aborder une une quelques questions sur
la relation de la france et de l'europe
avec des les principales puissances du
monde et celle du monde de demain en
premier lieu avec les états unis dont
vous venez de me parler un petit peu
pensez vous que la doctrine de charles
de gaulle qui pourrait être résumée par
la formule alliés amis alliés mais non
alignés est encore possible aujourd'hui
et dans un contexte où les états unis se
désintéresse peu à peu de l'europe pour
se tourner vers l'asie
c'est la poitrine du pivot que
pensez-vous du futur de la relation
transatlantique
je pense que la formule de de gaulle
reste parfaitement valable et au
contraire elles mêmes aujourd'hui en
train d'être d'être étendu à l'échelon
européen
alors donald trump il faut faudra quand
même le remercie un jour a fait beaucoup
pour faire avancer cette cette prise de
con
européenne parce que je pense que ça a
été un choc en particulier en allemagne
le donald trump a été un choc plus rudes
en allemagne qu'en france la france a
justement grâce à de gaulle
une sorte de deux d'expérience et elle
est vaccinée contre contre les foudres
ou contre le désamour américain
souvenons nous de de l'épisode de 2003
l'invasion de l'irak par les états unis
et les french fries mais les frites
françaises qui sont débaptisées
rebaptisé freedom fries parce que les
américains ne sont pas contents que la
france n'ait décidé de ne pas les suivre
en irak donc on a l'habitude et on a
cette expérience
en revanche les allemands ne n'étais pas
préparée à donald trump et le mépris
souverain dont il a fait preuve
vis-à-vis de l'europe et le dédain
vis-à-vis de l'allemagne
son obsession à vouloir punir les
voitures allemandes importés aux états
unis et le la manière extrêmement
cavalière avec laquelle il sait il s'est
comporté avec angela merkel ont provoqué
une vraie réflexion à une vraie prise de
conscience en allemagne et dans d'autres
pays européens
ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont prêts
qu'ils sont tous devenus gaullien on est
loin du compte et il est clair que le
retour de joe biden des démocrates d'une
administration beaucoup plus amicales et
coopératives avec l'europe fait baisser
cette nuit vos de tension mais ce qui
est certain aussi c'est que en allemagne
en particulier il ya cette prise de
conscience que c'est arrivé une fois ça
peut arriver une deuxième fois et que
effectivement comme vous l'avait dit il
ya le pivot vers l'asie reste donné
absolument fondamental de la diplomatie
américaine
quel que soit
aujourd'hui le cas de figure donc là la
règle absolument capital pour les
prochaines années c'est qu'effectivement
l'europe doit rester un allié des états
unis
il ya trop de deux d'éléments communs
trop de 2oc de d'habitude on ne
convaincra pas une bonne partie de
l'europe de renoncer à l'otan je pense
que la france s'en est fait une raison
depuis bien longtemps même si elle
aurait bien aimé que que les choses
changent
mais en tout cas c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui parce que le l'europe à une
sorte de 2,2 d'obsession du parapluie
américain et que tant que et on a bien
vu d'ailleurs que joe biden a mis moins
d'une semaine a proclamé son attachement
à l'article 5 de la charte atlantique
donc cet article qui détermine que si un
pays est attaqué tout le monde vient à
son secours
donald trump avait mis un en avant de
dire publiquement qu'il était attaché à
l'article 5 joe biden a mis en scène un
entretien vidéo avec stoltenberg le
secrétaire-général de l'otan pour
exprimer très vite quelques jours à
peine après être entré à la maison
blanche que cet engagement américain aux
côtés de l'europe existe est donc cette
réalité elle existe en revanche allié
mais pas alignée devrait être le maître
mot de la diplomatie européenne
vis-à-vis des etats-unis dans l'avenir
ça reste en tout cas clairement celui de
la de la politique française
et ça ça ne changera pas je pense quel
que soit le président en france on a pas
il ya une sorte de socle fondamental
culturelle en france aujourd'hui autour
de cette question et de cette idée de
cette approche de la relation
transatlantique
alors nous venons de parler globalement
de la civilisation occidentale de la
france de l'europe et maintenant des
états unis changeons directement de
civilisation si vous êtes d'accord sur
ces termes et évoquons désormais l'autre
grande puissance contemporaine de ce
monde que vous connaissez très bien
puisque comme vous l'avez dit vous avez
été correspondant à pékin pendant
plusieurs années
je vais bien entendu parler de la chine
alors selon vous quelles relations
futures peut-on envisager entre la
france et plus généralement l'europe et
la chine
devons-nous nous ranger du côté des
américains pour tenir tête à la
puissance chinoise en établissant un
camp occidental comme dans une logique
de guerre froide
ou devons-nous nous affirmer seul
européen face aux chinois c'est une
question structurant de notre époque
parce que l'émergence de la chine est
certainement le phénomène marquant des
20 dernières années et va conditionner
le reste du 21e siècle
c'est ce que c'est ce dont les
américains sont aujourd'hui absolument
persuadé et les européens
avec un peu de retard il faut refaire un
petit peu le fil de l'histoire d'abord
la france a été pionnière dans les
relations avec avec la chine de mao
intuition du général de gaulle dont nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure et qui donne
un petit plus à la france dans ses
relations avec avec pékin avec le fait
que les deux pays siègent au conseil de
sécurité que et qu'on retrouve la chine
finalement dans tout un tas de deux
dossiers y compris par exemple le
nucléaire iranien et c'est donc la
france a une place un peu particulière
la deuxième chose c'est que on a
on a mis du temps à comprendre que
l'émergence de la chine changer le monde
on l'a compris très vite sur le plan
économique mais on n'a pas compris sur
le plan stratégique et politique et et
je sais qu'en quand j'étais
correspondant en chine mais j'étais de
2000 à 2006 c'est c'est la chine est
rentré dans l'om c'est en 2001 donc
c'est vraiment le le l'époque du
décollage absolue et accélérer elle
avait à l'époque une croissance de 12
13% par an et à cette époque les hommes
d'affaires qu'on croisait les la vision
occidentale de la chine c'était en gros
on a un gros sous-traitants en chine et
on lui envoie toutes nos industries
polluantes
toutes les industries à basse valeur
ajoutée dont nous ne voulons plus et
nous évidemment occident conquérant nous
restons le les détenteurs de la valeur
ajoutée de la recherche de l'innovation
et c'est là que on s'est planté et qu'on
a mal compris la chine sait que la chine
c'est une grande puissance historique
c'est une civilisation vous devez
employer le mot à juste titre et elle
avait pour ambition de le redevenir de
re devenir une superpuissance et donc il
était clair dès les années 2000 qu'elle
ne se contenterait pas d'être le sous
traitant des des t-shirts à 1 euro et
des adjuvants de l'industrie chimique
qui polluent trop et qu'on ne peut plus
faire chez nous c'était évident qu'elle
voulait faire à la fois les t-shirts un
euro mais aussi les fusées pour la lune
et c'est ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui et
qu'elle le fait ce que nous n'avions pas
perçu également et anticiper c'est le
fait que en se développant et en
affirmant de plus en plus son autorité
elle deviendrait aussi
une une puissance normative c'est-à-dire
qu'elle qu'elle voulait avoir son propre
modèle et le présenter à la face du
monde et que ce modèle n'est pas notre
modèle démocratique que c'est un modèle
autoritaire qui de surcroît est
énormément basé sur le poids de la
technologie donc sorte de techno
autoritarisme donc tout ça c'est la
toile de fond de du monde d'aujourd'hui
que nous n'avions pas anticipé et donc
donald trump danse on a eu cette
intuition de lancer cette confrontation
avec la chine en particulier sur le
terrain économique et technologique mais
il l'a fait d'une manière extrêmement
maladroite il l'a fait de manière trop
ancien c'est à dire brouillonne
transactionnel donc lorsque les chinois
ont accepté de dépenser quelques
dizaines de milliards de plus en achats
de produits agricoles américains
il a levé le pied au mauvais moment
puisque c'était le moment de du duc au
vide et sans sans se soucier des autres
partenaires internationaux
c'est ce qu'essaye de corriger
aujourd'hui joe biden en proposant
effectivement au pays démocratique
l'europe l'australie le japon la corée
de se joindre à une sorte de bloc
occidental contre contre la chine
je ne suis absolument pas que persuadé
que ce soit une bonne idée est pas une
bonne idée en particulier pour l'europe
d'abord parce que les américains ont
leurs propres intérêts dans cette dans
cette affaire qui est ce qu'ils sont
ceux de dollars et de leurs économies de
leur géant industriel de de leurs
ambitions technologiques qui sont aussi
hégémonique que celle de la chine et que
nous n'avons pas nécessairement
intérêt à ce que ce soit ce monde-là qui
se dessine
en revanche nous avons un intérêt nous
européens et nous français à rétablir un
rapport de force avec la chine
aujourd'hui ce rapport de force n'existe
pas et tout à fait embryonnaire et et
peut être fait en collaboration avec
avec les états unis
oui il me semble et lorsque trump avait
commencé sa confrontation il ya déjà
trois quatre ans que l'une des bonnes
approches aurait été de dire de réunir
effectivement les européens et les
japonais les australiens et c'est tout
ce qu'ils avaient des des problèmes avec
le comportement de la chine notamment
sur la sphère économique et d'aller
devant l'om c'est l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et de poser un
certain nombre de problèmes en disant ça
ne peut plus marcher comme ça ça n'a pas
été la proche de trump et aujourd'hui ça
paraît beaucoup plus compliqué parce
qu'il ya un climat de guerre froide qui
s'est imposé dans le monde et est ce que
les européens peuvent avoir une double
politique c'est à dire être côtés des
américains pour peser face à la chine et
garder une autonomie dans leur relation
avec avec la chine
c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'ils essaient de
faire et je trouve assez maladroitement
hélas et notamment ça a été le cas dans
cet accord sur les investissements qui a
été conclu en décembre sous présidence
allemande mais c'est tout l'enjeu des
prochaines années et en particulier
cette question devient de plus en plus
compliqués à cet équilibre est de plus
en plus compliqué à tenir dans la mesure
où l'enjeu des droits de l'homme et est
revenu au premier plan
donald trump eux n'avaient pas grand
chose à faire des droits de l'homme joe
biden à une plus grande préoccupation
est en tout cas le placent plus haut
dans son agenda et c'est tant mieux
mais comment fait-on pour à la fois
accusé un pays de génocide
puisque c'est ce qui est en train de se
ses accusations qu'elle
être formulées à propos du sort des
ouigoure du xinjiang
mais est-ce qu'on peut d'un côté traiter
un pays d'être génocidaire et de l'autre
côté signé des accords d'investissement
qui garantissent nos intérêts
économiques
est ce que on peut on peut critiquer ce
que font les chinois à hong kong où ils
ont réduit complètement à néant
l'accord qui avait été signé avec les
britanniques
avec cette autonomie très forte le
fameux un pays deux systèmes qui est
aujourd'hui bafoués est-ce qu'on peut
d'un côté condamné ça et de l'autre côté
discuté climat ou discuter ou tenir les
jeux olympiques dans dans un an les
olympiques d'hiver dans un en chine donc
ça c'est extrêmement complexe de trouver
le bon niveau de dialogue et de
confrontation avec la chine
moi je ne crois pas que le monde ait un
intérêt à rentrer dans une nouvelle
logique de guerre froide c'est à dire de
d'abord si on l'analogie est que la
guerre froide trop vite ses limites dans
la mesure où il ya aujourd'hui une
imbrication des économies qui est
colossal et qui n'existait pas à
l'époque de la guerre froide entre
l'urss et les états unis
il y avait quasiment pas d'échangés
économiques pas d'investissement pas de
brassage humain avant la pandémie avait
encore trois cent cinquante mille
étudiants chinois aux états unis
donc on est loin de 2 de pouvoir séparer
les les deux blocs aussi facilement
tesla vient de d'ouvrir une nouvelle
usine à shanghai et les iphone et où les
ordinateurs que nous achetons dans nos
magasins sont tous fabriqués en chine il
ya il ya il ya quelque chose de 2,2
gigantesque dans cette ce brassage entre
les deux mondes qui ce qui sera très
difficile à réduire en revanche 1 et
salue la pandémie nous l'a montré
nous avons un intérêt absolument vital à
réduire notre dépendance vis-à-vis de la
chine dans les secteurs qu'on peut juger
stratégique
que ce soit la production de médicaments
le certain nombre de composants
électroniques dont on voit bien qu'ils
qui sont une source de tension comme les
microprocesseurs etc
mais ça ne remet ça ne venait pas la
même chose que de dire on va rentrer
dans une logique de guerre froide où il
y aura deux blocs dans le monde le blanc
que le bloc occidental avec ses alliés
et le blog chinois avec les siens ça je
pense que ça serait une erreur quant à
irait pendant longtemps dans le monde
donc comment arriver à retrouver un
équilibre avec les chinois je pense que
ça sera très difficile et que la
situation va d'abord se détériorer avant
d'arriver à à peut-être trouvé trouvé
cet équilibre
ça va se détériorer parce que il va
falloir créer un rapport de force et que
la chine résonne d'abord en matière de
rapport de force aujourd'hui elle est là
sort auro parlons plus pardon je termine
juste une phrase elle a le sentiment que
l'occident est en décadence est en
déclin et que son heure est arrivée et
ça n'incite pas à être plus souple vous
vous parlez de rapport de force
justement et ça me c'est m'amène à vous
poser une question sur de grandes
puissances qui sont qui ont une
proximité géographique avec l'europe que
sont la russie et la turquie et au cours
de ces deux dernières au secours de ces
dernières années ces pays se sont
montrés bien plus bien plus virulent que
conciliant à l'égard des pays européens
selon vous est ce que la théorie du choc
des civilisations de samuel huntington
donc dans ce cas là entre les
civilisations occidentales orthodoxe et
islamique
peut-être éclairante pour comprendre la
montée des rapports de force
ou est ce tout simplement le signe de la
main déclin du droit et de la
coopération internationale au profit du
retour des états puissance
alors moi je pense que ça melting tonnes
a peut-être pointé du doigt des éléments
qui irait qui était pertinent mais il
s'est trompé sur sur beaucoup de choses
et en particulier les lignes de clivage
aujourd'hui dans le monde ne sont pas
celles qui l'avaient décrit il avait par
exemple imaginer une alliance entre le
monde islamique et et la chine on voit
bien que la chine dans son comportement
aussi une langue essaye au contraire d'
éradiquer l'islam et les religions même
si elle peut avoir une alliance
politique avec l'arabie saoudite où
d'autres pays islamiques autoritaires ou
avec le pakistan par exemple
donc non moi j'élimine la thèse de
huntington en revanche je disais tout à
l'heure il ya l'émergence d'un monde
multipolaire chaotique et c'est là que
que que se trouve aujourd'hui la source
de toute la stabilité mondiale c'est que
nous sommes passés en relativement peu
de temps en tout cas de mon vivant à moi
c'est à dire dans une vie humaine de cet
ordre bipolaire de la guerre froide
soviéto américain moi j'ai j'ai je suis
allé à berlin est en passant par
checkpoint charlie avec une boule au
ventre tellement ce cadre de la guerre
froide était et est pesant c'était dans
les années 80 c'est n'y a pas si
longtemps
ensuite on a connu cette ère post guerre
froide avec une seule superpuissance les
états unis et un optimisme général que
voilà le monde allait entrer dans une
ère de coopération de de démocratisation
de de respect des droits humains etc
j'ai un souvenir ma d'être allé à vienne
où il y avait une certain nombre de
grandes conférences des nations unies
dans les années 90 celle de vienne
étaient sur les droits de l'homme
il y avait dix mille participants venus
du monde entier
il y avait 600 ong
des philippines il y avait un optimisme
à cette époque sur le fait que voilà on
a été entré dans une ère nouvelle
même si au même moment il faut bien le
dire il y avait la guerre en yougoslavie
et peu de temps après le génocide au
rwanda
mais voilà on est passé de cette terre
où il y avait donc une seule
superpuissance les états unis à et sans
s'en rendre compte
d'une certaine manière on est on est
entré dans une ère multipolaire dans
laquelle il ya plus de règles du jeu
avec l'émergence de la chine on en a
parlé mais l'émergence de puissances
régionales qui ont pris leur autonomie
alors la turquie est un bon exemple la
turquie est certes un ancien empire et
qui a beaucoup de moteurs qui sont issus
de cet adn impérial d'antan et on le
sent bien chez chez air douanes le
président turc et la turquie est à la
fois membre de l'otan elle a été même un
membre important de l'otan sur son flanc
oriental mais elle a aujourd'hui un jeu
qui est le sien en libye en syrie
elle l'a montré récemment dans le dans
le caucase avec la guerre entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie autour du
karabagh donc on voit bien que c'est une
puissance qui as à son autonomie de
pensée son autonomie d'action tout en
étant dans cet héritage d'alliance
d'autrefois et la russie autre ancien
empire d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière
renoue avec ses son passé et que ce soit
l'enjeu le passé russe ou soviétique par
par son activisme internationale avec un
vladimir poutine qui a lui aussi qui vit
dans cette eau si cette nostalgie de
puissance d'antan pourquoi l'europe est
ballotté aujourd'hui parce que l'europe
une expression as tu es à la mode où on
dit l'europe est un ensemble végétariens
dans un monde carnivores l'europe
n'était pas prête à se cet univers
brutal et elle est ballottée à ses
frontières aujourd'hui par une russie
qui ne la ménage pas par une turquie qui
rue dans les brancards et l'europe vient
seulement de comprendre que qu'elle ne
ne peut pas continuer à exister en tant
dans l'autre joue si je peux me
permettre l'expression et qu'elle doit
en tout cas restaurer une crédibilité de
puissance et ce mot fait très mal en
europe
c'est clément ball le ministre des
affaires européennes qui qui disait
l'autre jour j'ai trouvé que c'était une
remarque très pertinente que l'europe
s'était construite sur la négation de la
puissance pourquoi on a créé le les
prémices de l'europe avec la communauté
charbon et acier puis la communauté
européenne et enfin l'union européenne
c'était à l'époque avait initialement
pour empêcher une nouvelle guerre entre
la france et l'allemagne pour contenir
pour faire rentrer le génie de la
puissance dans la bouteille et et ça a
marché puisque nous avons eu 70 ans de
de paix dans cet ensemble européen qui
avait été à l'origine des deux
précédentes guerres mondiales
en revanche aujourd'hui on est dans la
jonction contradictoire c'est-à-dire
qu'après nous avoir dix pendant 70 ans
surtout ne pensez pas à des rêves de
puissance on nous dit mais il faut vous
comporter comme une puissance dans un
monde qui ne respectent que la puissance
et donc c'est une révolution culturelle
très compliqué à faire aujourd'hui pour
les européens de se penser en puissance
collective
après avoir construit un ensemble qui
était la lentille puissance donc mais
y'a qu'à ce prix là qu'on aura des
relations plus normales avec des voisins
comme la russie ou la turquie qui
aujourd'hui sont dans une phase où il ne
raisonne qu'en termes de puissance
donc oui l'europe
doit tenir compte de cette évolution du
monde d'aujourd'hui parce que on
arrivera à recréer des règles du jeu
international a trouvé une gouvernance
mondiale et du respect entre les
ensembles que lorsque tout le monde aura
compris que la force ne suffit pas à
réguler les relations internationales et
ça ça passe par la création de ces
nouveaux rapports de force est bien
sorti maintenant de ces considérations
de puissance entre blog de civilisation
et reconcentre nous un petit peu sur sur
la france plus particulièrement sur la
francophonie
alors à votre avis quelles opportunités
ses centaines de millions de locuteurs
de la langue française peuvent-ils
offrir à notre pays des points de vue
diplomatique économique ou culturel et
ensuite évidemment je voulais aborder ce
point on sait que la très grande
majorité des francophones se trouvent
sur le continent africain qui de
surcroît est en pleine expansion
démographique
alors quel rôle la france doit jouer en
afrique en trouvant un juste équilibre
entre néo colonialisme et intérêts et
des intérêts pardon la question de la
francophonie est intéressante et on n'a
jamais réussi à lui donner du sens et ça
c'est une
je trouve que c'est une un échec des des
50 dernières années on n'a jamais réussi
à faire de la francophonie une réalité
au sens diplomatique ou ou même d'
influence réelle
toutes les tentatives ont échoué
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie le relief reste une
coquille vide qui qui ne parvient pas
réellement à a existé et c'est dommage
parce que je rejoins la deuxième partie
de votre question à ce moment là c'est
que la francophonie aurait pu être un
moyen pour la france de réinventer sa
politique africaine
nous avons un péché originel
à expier d'une certaine manière je suis
pas un adepte de la repentance mais il
se trouve que là le péché originel est
lourd qui est celui de la françafrique
oui se trouve que j'ai commencé ma
carrière en afrique d'abord en afrique
du sud puis ensuite quand je suis passé
à libération je me suis occupé de la
rubrique afrique pendant sept ans et
donc j'ai sillonné toute l'afrique
tout y compris france anglophones et
francophones et j'avoue que je reste
encore aujourd'hui sidéré par ce que par
le le ska et et le néocolonialisme
français en afrique francophone
quand on arrivait au gabon en côte
d'ivoire où les conseillers français lé
chef de la garde présidentielle français
faisait la loi et imposer leur loi aux
dirigeants africains ont il ya eu
quelques il ya eu 20 ans de 2,2 non
respect et d'humiliation de deux de ces
pays que qu'on a voulu perpétuer avec
une fausse indépendance jeu sujet des
mots très durs parce que franchement ce
que les souvenirs que j'en ai parlé à 40
ans alors ça a beaucoup changé depuis
mais ses souvenirs l'art est très fort
et ont marqué une relation avec
l'afrique et aujourd'hui on le voit
regardez ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques jours seulement à dakar le
lorsque la population se soulève les
jeunes se soulèvent pour une raisons de
politique intérieure c'est à dire
l'arrestation du principal dirigeant de
l'opposition ballet cible des émeutiers
sont les supermarchés auchan
les stations total et les stations de
péage de l'autoroute qui sont gérés par
une société française
eiffage c'est à dire que la puissance ex
coloniale reste l'incarnation de
pouvoir peut-être plus encore que le
président lui-même
c'était un grand paradoxe parce que
franchement par rapport à l'époque que
je décrivais des années 80 la fluence
française aujourd'hui c'est énormément
réduite et la france n'a plus laissé
levier d'influencé qu'elle avait
autrefois
et en plus si on regarde les chiffres de
l'économie
la chine est beaucoup plus influentes
économiquement dandy compris dans les
pays d'afrique francophone quand la côte
d'ivoire est le seul pays d'afrique
subsaharienne dans lequel la france
reste le premier partenaire commercial
dans tous les autres c'est la chine donc
c'est quand même assez paradoxal que la
france soit la première cible mais ça
reste le cas et toutes les tentatives
qui ont été faites de réinventer la
politique africaine
emmanuel macron qui a voulu jouer sur le
privilège de l'âge c'est à dire qu'il
est il n'a aucun passé aucun passif
néocolonial avec l'afrique son premier
rapport avec l'afrique est d'ailleurs
été son stage de de lena qui l'avait
fait au nigeria donc un pays anglophone
il a essayé de jouer cette carte-là
notamment dans son premier déplacement
en afrique avec ce dialogue avec la
jeunesse africaine à ouagadougou et et
on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'il n'arrive
pas à dépasser ce stade d'abord parce
que le premier instrument le plus
visible de la présence française en
afrique ça reste l'armé avec la
situation au sahel et que deuxièmement
il est obligé de composer avec avec les
régimes en place
la france est par exemple muette en ce
moment face à adé situation de pouvoir
qui s'éternise et qui sont
insupportables
le président biya qui est le cas au
pouvoir depuis 40 ans bientôt 40 ans au
cameroun denis sassou n'guesso qui se
représente pour son énième mandat au
congo brazzaville
moi j'étais à yaoundé quand paul biya
est devenu président c'était en 1982 et
à l'époque c'était un jeune technocrate
plein d'avenir et les congolais cameroun
nés étaient ravis et penser que tout
allait changer tout allait s'ouvrir
aujourd'hui paul biya est un autocrate
vieillissant qui a mis son pays en coupe
réglée à la fois démocratiquement
économiquement c'est la france ne peut
rien faire la france ne va pas renverser
paul biya est donc comme elle ne peut
rien faire elle le cautionne et aux yeux
des camerounais la france couvre un
président qui qui n'a que trop duré donc
il ya une contradiction absolument
infernal dans notre approche de
l'afrique francophone qui rend toute
réforme très compliqué on a des
relations beaucoup plus des cons
décontracté décomplexé avec le nigeria
avec le kenya où avec l'afrique du sud
avec lesquels il n'y a pas ce passif
delà de la françafrique donc moi je
reste persuadé que l'afrique et le pour
employer une expression l'avenir de la
france d'une certaine manière c'est à
dire que l'europe la france et l'europe
non de de deux places dans l'avenir à
long terme que dans un rapport très
étroit de collaboration avec l'afrique
avec le continent africain qui va être
dans quelques décennies à la fois le
continent le plus peuplé au monde si on
le prend collectivement ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait la réalité mais bref avec 2
milliard d'habitants à la fin du siècle
mais aussi potentiellement un vrai
relais de croissance à l'europe et ce
partenariat euro africain qui peut faire
du sens et c'est pour ça que d'une
certaine manière la france a tout
intérêt à jouer une carte européenne
dans ses relations avec l'afrique parce
qu'elle n'arrivera pas elle a surmonté
son son passé et son passif avec avec
l'afrique francophone d'accord alors
merci merci pour vos réponses
malheureusement c'est déjà la fin de
cette entrevue
elle fut particulièrement intéressante
et je pense qu'elle va plaire à nos
auditeurs que ce qu'elle nous a permis
d'aborder de nombreux thèmes sur
l'europe et les états unis la chine la
défense la francophonie etc
merci à vous et non de scopeo pour le
temps que vous nous avez accordé et
maintenant je vais laisser la parole est
le cas pour qu'il puisse conclure merci
bien voulu d'abord je dois aussi vous
remercier parce que c'est un éventail de
questions et de sujets extrêmement
important et je pense que c'est c'est
qu'ils sont souvent trop ignorée dans le
débat public en france
et oui comme quand même il ya là dit je
vous remercie également au nom de toute
l'équipe de scoopeo l'observatoire
politique pour toutes ces réponses
honnêtes précise et qui sont qui reflète
votre expertise et votre carrière qui
est déjà avec très longue et on a
vraiment abordé tout un éventail de
questions passionnantes sur laquelle on
n'a pas l'habitude de parler sur scopeo
puisqu'on on se concentre précisément
sur les questions nationales et là on a
pu n'a pu partir de la france pour
parler des questions internationales qui
sont tout aussi patiente alors nous vous
remercions une nouvelle fois et nous
nous invitons tous nos auditeurs à
retrouver l'ensemble de nos entrevues
politique sur notre chaîne youtube et
nos articles tribunes dossier d' analyse
sur notre site ce coupé au point robe
encore merci beaucoup à vous monsieur à
skis merci à vous y voir